A 13-YEAR MYSTERY TO AN END.
JULIAN HERNANDEZ WAS IN THE
LEGAL CUSTODY OF HIS MOTHER WHEN
HE VANISHED IN ALABAMA IN AUGUST
OF 2002.
AT THE TIME HE WAS JUST 5 YEARS
OF AGE.
FAST FORWARD TO THIS PAST
WEEKEND, THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY
SAYS THE 18-YEAR-OLD WHO WAS
FILLING OUT A COLLEGE
APPLICATION WHEN HE DISCOVERED
HIS SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER DID
NOT MATCH HIS NAME.
IT WAS THEN THAT HE AND A SCHOOL
COUNSELOR REALIZED HE WAS LISTED
IN THE NATIONAL CENTER FOR
MISSING SKPEX EXPLOITED CHILDREN
DATABASE.
THAT'S WHEN POLICE IN ALABAMA
GOT A PHONE CALL.
>> I RECEIVED A CALL ASKING IF
HERNANDEZ WAS STILL MISSING THAT
THEY SAW WHERE HE WAS MISSING
SINCE 2002.
WE DID SOME CHECKING AND
DISCOVERED HE WAS STILL REPORTED
MISSING AND HAD NOT BEEN TALKED
TO.
THEY WENT AND TALKED TO HIM.
THEY WENT AND TALKED TO THE
FATHER.
THAT'S WHEN IDENTIFICATION WAS
MADE.
>> SHORT TIME LATER, THE TEEN'S
FATHER WAS ARRESTED.
JEAN CASAREZ HAS BEEN WORKING
THIS FOR US.
13 YEARS, YOU'VE GOT TO BE
KIDDING.
>> AND THE FATHER WAS ARRESTED
ON AGGRAVATED IDENTITY THEFT IN
OHIO BECAUSE HE ALLEGEDLY
FALSIFIED TO GET AN OHIO STATE
I.D. ASSUMING AN IDENTITY HE IS
NOT.
HE'S BEING HELD ON $250,000
BAIL.
BUT THIS ALL STARTED SO
INNOCENTLY.
A YOUNG 16-YEAR-OLD TRYING TO GO
TO COLLEGE.
AND IT WOULD HAVE BEEN IN 2002
WHEN HE WAS 5 YEARS OLD THAT HE
ALLEGEDLY WAS ABDUCTED FROM HIS
MOTHER IN ALABAMA.
I JUST GOT OFF THE PHONE WITH
THE POLICE DEPARTMENT THAT TELLS
ME BECAUSE THERE ARE NO OHIO
CHARGES YET, TELLS ME THAT
FEDERAL AND STATE AUTHORITIES
MIGHT BE LOOKING AT RIGHT NOW
WHAT CHARGES TO BRING, AS WE
SPEAK.
BUT HE ALSO TOLD ME, AND THIS IS
THE PUBLIC INFORMATION OFFICER,
THAT THE MOTHER AND FATHER WERE
NOT MARRIED.
THERE MAY BE SOME ISSUES WITH
CHARGES, HE SAID.
IT IS HIS BIOLOGICAL SON.
BUT HE WAS VERY WELL RAISED AND
WAS A VERY GOOD STUDENT.
SO I ACTUALLY LOOKED AT FEDERAL
KIDNAPPING LAWS BECAUSE IT'S
CROSSING STATE LINES.
IT DOESN'T INCLUDE A PARENT
UNLESS THERE'S BEEN A COURT
ORDER SAYING THAT THAT PARENTAL
RIGHT HAS BEEN TERMINATED.
SO A LOT WE DON'T KNOW ABOUT
THIS STORY AT THIS POINT.
BUT WE DID GET A STATEMENT FROM,
FIRST OF ALL, LET'S GO WITH THE
FAMILY, THE MOTHER OF JULIAN,
THAT HAS NOT HAD HER SON FOR 13
YEARS.
SHE TOLD CNN, OUR FAMILY WAS
OVERJOYED THIS WEEK TO LOCATE
JULIAN AND LEARN HE'S SAFE.
WE WANT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR
THEIR PRAYERS AND SUPPORT DURING
JULIAN'S DISAPPEARANCE.
AND ALSO THE NATIONAL CENTER FOR
MISSING AND EXPLOITED CHILDREN
GOT A HINT OF THE REALITY HERE.
THEY TELL US WE APPLAUD JULIAN
HERNANDEZ FOR HIS COURAGE IN
TAKING THE FIRST STEPS TO FIND
ANSWERS A ABOUT WHO HE IS.
>> HOW IS HE DOING?
>> WELL, THE STATEMENT FROM HIS
MOTHER GOES ON THAT IT PLEASE
GIVE US OUR PRIVACY AS HE IS
FOCUSED ON THIS EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT PERIOD OF TIME IN HIS
LIFE.
>> IT MAKES YOU WONDER